There are plenty of studies that demonstrate yoga's potential for health.
For example, Oxford University found that people who practice yoga...
...even once a week were less stressed out,...
...had lower blood pressure and slept better at night.
And yoga is not just good for your mental health.
According to the National Institute of Health,...
...it's proven to help with musculoskeletal issues...
...especially lower back pain.
It can even help relieve asthma.
There are tons of different types of yoga...
...all with names that are kind of difficult to remember.
There's hatha, bikram, vinyasa, the list goes on.
And while some types do encourage a hard workout...
...where you bend and flex in insane positions and sweat bullets,...
...yoga can more simply be just used as a meditative tool.
And you get the same mental health benefits.